je suis Malik Konaté je suis journaliste
malien j'ai quitté le pays le 1er
septembre pour rejoindre Dakar à cause
des menaces et des intimidations pays et
après je suis venu à Paris ici depuis le
mois de janvier je suis là
[Musique]
s'il faut avoir des bonnes sources et il
faut avoir des contacts c'est ce que moi
je fais d'ailleurs pour continuer
toujours à commenter l'actualité
malienne je donne un exemple le dernier
reportage que nous avons fait avec ma
boîte c'était une école se trouve plein
cœur de Bamako sur une île au bord même
du fleuve et les enfants prennent la
pirogue pour aller à l'école le matin à
7h pour retourner à la maison
l'après-midi donc nous avons traité ce
sujet la distance parce que nous avons
été alerté par les parents d'élèves donc
nous continuons toujours
d'exercer ce métier à distance à travers
nos sources et nos connaissances au pays
qui nous envoie certaines informations
[Musique]
je travaille avec cinq personnes au sein
de cette boîte de production c'est un
média en ligne là où nous faisons des
reportages de société salive des sujets
de société nous arrivons à avoir un
modèle économique une permet de prendre
en charge même
étant donné que je ne suis pas au pays
mais quand même mes collègues qui
travaillent là-bas essaie de travailler
parce que quelque part on a quand même
pour prendre certaines dépenses en
charge dans ce cadre là que je continue
toujours d'exercer le métier parce que
pour moi il faut jamais donner raison à
nos détracteurs parce qu'en tant que
journaliste nous ne sommes ni ennemis ni
amis de quelqu'un on est là pour
raconter des faits de ce qui se passe
sur le terrain
une fois que les gens nous alertent à
travers les réseaux sociaux pour nous
dire tiens Malik il y a telle
information il y a telle chose qui se
passe dans notre localité
automatiquement j'essaie de chercher des
contacts j'essaie de contacter d'autres
personnes mes confrères journalistes ou
d'autres personnes autour de moi pour
avoir des contacts au niveau de ces
localités là pour pouvoir
traiter le sujet et vérifier
l'information s'il faut prendre contact
avec l'administration les élus le coup
est aussi des notabilité
le leaders d'opinion pour que au moins
s'ils puissent nous donner leur version
des faits et j'ai une traite jamais un
sujet sans avoir trois sources au moins
pour me rassurer de la fiabilité de
l'information parce que une source peut
se tromper mais j'aime source oui mais
trois sources ne peut pas se tromper à
la fois